hi and Carmichael and welcome to another
edition of modeling the masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow your business is
to model the strategies of people who
have already done what you're trying to
do so today we're going to look at how a
young entrepreneur from the Bronx
started a job selling neckties and
turned it into a multibillion-dollar
Empire this is the story of Ralph Lauren
and a cop three lessons that you can
learn from his success Ralph Lauren born
Ralph
Lipschitz is an American fashion
designer and business executive best
known for his Polo Ralph Lauren clothing
brand his father a house painter changed
the family name to Lauren when Ralph was
a teenager while in high school
Lauren worked at a tie store as a stock
boy after school
he often sold ties to his classmates
Kerner commission he sold ties for
twelve to fifteen dollars when even
luxury ties didn't sell for more than
five dollars after high school Lauren
enlisted in the US Army and then joined
the Brooks Brothers clothing company as
a tie salesman he had a vision for
creating a new line of ties but Brooks
Brothers wasn't interested so Lauren
found the time here in Cincinnati and
started his own business
today his Polo Ralph Lauren company has
almost 5 billion dollars in revenues and
employees close to 20,000 people as of
2011 Forbes estimates his wealth at 5.8
billion dollars which would make Ralph
Lauren the 173rd richest person in the
world
by following his passion even as a young
high schooler Ralph Lauren was able to
turn a job he liked into a multi-billion
dollar company to help you profit from
your passion here are three action items
you can learn from Ralph Lauren action
item number one stick to your vision
almost every single successful
entrepreneur that I profile had a vision
for their company when they first
started out they wanted to change how
something was done in their industry
they looked at the world in a slightly
different way and wanted others to join
them that vision can be fuel to help you
get through the lean startup days don't
stray from it to do something that might
make you some short-term money but isn't
fulfilling and doesn't align with the
vision you have for yourself when Lauren
was getting started he approaches
Bloomingdale's to sell his ties it was a
flagship brand that would rock at his
company forward
they met with Lauren and told him they
would carry his ties if he made them
narrower and replaced his label on the
back with the Bloomingdale label Lauren
refused and lost his big account he went
on to sell to other companies and had
the last laugh and Bloomingdale's came
back to ask for a second chance once
they saw how well his ties were selling
with their competitors
according to Lauren your vision is very
important you should know whom you're
selling to what your marketing
advertising says about you and whom it's
speaking to me personally I don't try to
please everyone I understand who I'm
selling to and I work towards that
vision all the time action Adam number
two evolve your brand don't reinvent it
your business never turns out exactly as
you thought it would it's important to
have a clear vision and let the tactics
you use be flexible as you grow so you
don't constrict yourself a great way to
expand your business is to evolve your
brand and offer new products or services
that you can sell to the same customer
the easiest way to grow a business is to
sell more to current customers the
hardest way to grow is to try and find
new customers
always look to your customer base to see
what problems they have and if you can
offer anything else that might help
solve them Lauren started out in the
necktie business but quickly expanded
into a lifestyle brand that people
connected with he wanted to continue to
expand his business into new product
lines I had to make sure that those
products were consistent with the image
and brand that he wanted to portray
today you can wear Lauren clothing by
Lauren paint dry yourself off with
Lauren towels sit down and Lauren
furniture and the list goes on according
to Lauren what I do is about living it's
about living the best life you can and
enjoying the fullness of the life around
you from what you wear to the way you
live to the way you love when you think
of the blur of all the brands that are
out there the ones you believe in and
the ones you remember like Chanel and
Armani are the ones that stand for
something fashion is about establishing
an image that consumers can adapt to
their own individuality and it's an
image that can change that can involve
it doesn't reinvent itself every two
years
action atom number three trust your
instincts you very rarely have enough
information to make most of the big
decisions are going to have to make with
your business by the time you get all
the information it's likely too late to
act so you're going to have to trust
your instincts listen to the voice
inside you and trust that you're doing
the right thing if you have a true
passion for what you're doing then your
instincts will rarely lead you down the
wrong path Lauren never went to fashion
school and only took a few business
courses at a City College on paper and
looked like he was never going to make
it but he had the ability to trust his
instincts and follow what the trends
were in his market he listened to his
customers and gave them exactly what
they wanted as a result his business
exploded he continues to listen even now
as his company brings in billions of
dollars a company meetings for example
he offers his interns the opportunity to
speak out wants to hear the opinions and
tastes of the up-and-coming generation
they are the ones who will be deciding
his fate down the road
according to Lauren it's about
broadening your scope through history
and live in your life tune in and pay
attention
so remember stick to your vision evolve
your brand and trust your instincts to
finish up this video I wanted to share
one of my favorite true stories about
Ralph Lauren and some of his best quotes
in 1968 with the help of a $50,000 loan
Lauren founded polo fashions he chose
the name not because he liked the sport
he'd never played polo before in his
life
but to Lauren the name symbolized power
and style in image he wanted his clothes
to project according to Lauren I've
always loved sports but it didn't make
much sense to call my brand basketball
or baseball
so I decided on polo of course I didn't
play polo but I liked that it
represented a feeling of being
international European and yet very
healthy American it was a sport of kings
it was glamorous sexy and international
you
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the monsters if you
enjoyed and want to see more please give
it a thumbs up I'd also love to hear
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment below the video and stay
tuned for the next episode